I like your new haircut Rob makes you
look years younger Trevor I think you
need a better put on your
glasses welcome Jonathan Taylor to this
statistical learning
team the statistical learning edex
course was developed by Rob tip shirani
and myself in
2014 with an updated Edition in
2021 the course explains the concepts of
statistical learning and he is based on
our book co-authored with Gareth James
and Daniela Wht called an introduction
to statistical learning with
applications in R the second edition was
published in in
2021 here we present a new course
statistical learning with python along
with our new co-author and python expert
Jonathan
Taylor thank you
dor the course is based on our new book
an introduction to statistical learning
with applications in Python in the
course and in the book all the labs at
the end of each chapter are implemented
in Python we provide by Jupiter python
notebooks as well as a python package
islp the package contains all the data
sets used in the book along with many
new and useful tools for statistical
modeling wowers Jonathan I'm so excited
about this book o wowers that's a bit
sus Trevor I think that goes back to the
80s oof you're right
ye great to have you on board
Jonathan Jonathan is an early Python
adopter and has made many contributions
to the community like the earlier book
The PDF of this book is available for
free from the stat learning website
along with python resources we hope you
enjoy the
class